[Music]
okay everyone so this is my spoiler
review of euphoria season two
episode four as always this is written
and directed by sam
levinson i'm going to break my review
into three parts we're going to start
with rue and jules storyline in this
episode then we'll go to maddie's
birthday party and we'll finish up with
cal's story so
what we open this episode with is the
sequence where jules is going down on
rue and rue is thinking about how much
he loves jewels during this and i like
that they did a nice touch with all
these classic movies like titanic
brokeback mountain i love the cartoon
they did as well here of rue and jewels
and that it makes sense because we know
rue in this show is a huge film nerd and
geek and knows all the references so it
makes sense she's thinking of her love
in that kind of term and it's a nice
throwback with the titanic another film
that is a leo dicaprio film like they
wore for romeo and juliet in season one
but with euphoria
when everything is something good
there's something bad in it and
unfortunately she's like she says she's
on all these narcos she feels nothing of
this orgasm she's supposed to be feeling
here because she mentions her first time
someone going down on her and she
decides to fake an orgasm so
jules can see right through this it's
not a good fake orgasm right but this
actually will lead now to what
this episode sets up for the storyline
of jewels in rue where
jules now is going towards elliot right
and that elliott like they've said in
the after shows for euphoria that
elliot's this version that reminds
jewels of rue right where roo was in her
better state that's kind of what elliot
is to her this was the rule we saw at
points in last season that jules really
loved where the rule we're seeing now is
in a dark hole a really bad space of
heavy drugs where elliot does drugs but
elliot's there you know he's not in this
deep hole that rue is in and that's not
gonna help either right that's hurting
their intimacy that she can't even have
an orgasm because she's on so many drugs
and it's the problem you know that can
happen to certain drug addicts where all
they have on their mind and love is this
drug it ruins everything around them it
takes away from stuff they really should
be loving like a pleasurable moment in
sex elliot and jules are having a joke
about rue's fake orgasm and it leads
them having their most intimate moment
yet where elliot's showing jules how he
goes down on someone through a hand and
they start kissing and then they start
doing this behind rue's back when she's
even there and it will slowly process to
a bigger decision by jules later on
which we'll get to but you see just
visually they're showing you moments of
elliott's mindset here because
elliott leaves the room after ruined to
the bathroom now he goes to the bathroom
and she left a solo cup there with heavy
drugs under it and
elliot decides not to do them blows them
away but it's just showing you the
guilty's feeling towards jules that he's
not telling jules what roo is actually
doing he knows way more than jules does
about the heavy drug use and you'll see
in this episode rue and jules have
tension from the start that starts with
this very strange
you know they keep doing the truth or
dares elliot but they're daring each
other to basically do something intimate
with elliott in front of each other and
it gets competitive and odd and where we
see the darkest side of addiction but
also happens here with roux is after
they rob the liquor store
elliott noticed and says to her like yo
you can't be drinking on those drugs so
it's selfish of rue obviously it makes
everyone around them uncomfortable i
think we've all been there around
someone who's doing something that's way
too much and they shouldn't be because
it's scaring everybody but again jules
is just looking at us like she shouldn't
be drinking in general she doesn't know
she's on all these other drugs as well
at this point but jules confronts her
about the drinks like you don't drink
why are you doing that and roo just goes
just drop me off i can't stand you to
jewels so this was harsh and this is
where rue
does get dropped off goes home and jules
has just basically had it with her but
this is even before she learns the
information from elliott which will
happen because when jules and elliot go
back to elliot's place
she's going to take a shower i like they
did it visually too where she's kind of
cleansing herself of rue here and is
thinking about making this big choice of
sleeping with elliot she turns her phone
off but this is where elliott feels the
guilt to really hit in and decides
before he might have this intimate
jewels he has to get this guilt off his
chest and elliot elliott fesses up
saying roo's not sober hasn't been since
i met her but doing everything from
heroin to fentanyl to benzos
i know that because i've been doing it
with her i'm so sorry i just you want to
keep lying to you so
wow like someone telling the truth in
the show of euphoria it's a rare thing
and it's a rare thing to even see guilt
in some of these characters so it's kind
of a breath of fresh air to see that
elliott did the right thing and actually
told jules what's really going on and
that he has some
conscience here and this was the last
straw for jules clearly because she and
her head was thinking rue was just doing
weed not actually doing all these heavy
drugs that are a complete downfall for
her now it could be a mix obviously of
jules and denial about it and that she
was already kind of on to it clearly
because i think it's kind of silly that
she wouldn't recognize at all that you
know rue is doing more than just weed
but i'm sure that's part of the denial
part of it and now hearing it out loud
from elliott clearly makes her face it
now on the other end with ruiner house
the worst possible thing for her is to
have a suitcase full of drugs and we
know they put a good threat here for her
right that the woman she's doing this
business with doesn't mess around and
it's like if you screw up this money i'm
giving you i'll literally sell you off
to someone terrible so that also is
something that is really bad because you
can't trust a drug addict to just be
running a business in any form even if
it's drugs so this is where it's really
bad for rue and this leads to some of my
favorite stuff we've seen euphoria yet
and that starts with rue in her drug
days entering this church and you see
jules and elliot are in the pews here
and the singer here in the church is
singing i'll be on my way lord you know
i tried
while hugging her and then becomes her
father and i like this because this is
something people from clamoring for to
get back to the core of rue here and
that trauma she had of losing her father
at a young age and she's like i'm sorry
i let you down and the dad's like why
she's like because i'm not a good person
he says that's not true and she says you
don't really know me anymore and he says
yes i do i'm always with you
this leads to the most haunting scene
that i can remember in recent time
watching show and and tragic and
powerful in so many ways is
while she's having this moment the way
they cut from a shot of our perspective
someone spectating rue here is from a
distance outside the window and her just
hugging and with her father and you're
seeing someone basically on heroin here
and there's nobody there it's
so haunting and it works so well so
props to sale evans in for that that's
some of just the magic of this show and
it really hit so i think that just as a
whole is my favorite shot of the show
period we have seen yet and then at
least one of my favorite sequences
that's this crazy church organ at the
end of the episode that's playing with
this song please i tried shazaming it i
don't know what the song is if anyone
finds out leave in the comments i'd
really appreciate it i loved it and with
this narration of rue talking to jewels
like i love you i've always been with
you before you were born until after
you're gone and jules even says the end
of this
since we before we even existed so it's
very experimental stuff and now i don't
know if i'm looking too much into this
but they did show a shot
of elliot wiping jewel's thigh and
there's two cuts there i don't know if
this is alluding to her cutting because
this isn't foreign to jules because we
did see her cut herself in front of nate
as a moment to get nade away from her
but you know is this alluding to that
she's starting to cut i'm not sure and
did anyone else think we're gonna lose
roux here like it really scared me the
way that lyric was about you know moving
on this whole sequence and her thing
about her dad it was very dark to me we
know she's suicidal and
i was very afraid here that that might
lead to something like that it would be
shocking again because it's the lead of
the show it is zendaya here but
it wouldn't surprise me euphoria really
has no rules that anything can happen
with this show and before we even get
into the cassie story on this episode i
have to mention even in the sequence how
great the shot was of cassie and all
these flowers and she is a
representative of how she's the extreme
femininity side of this show her
character of cassie but with these pink
flowers and her wearing the pink but
also it reminded me eerily of a funeral
and having all these flowers a lot of
people predicting cassie won't make it
at the end of the season because she's
going down this really bad road here but
we'll get into that and it also again we
see that multiple times episode like the
visual side of this is like referencing
old paintings
which is really cool i think obviously
the cinematography is amazing in the
show and it just shows here but overall
this last ending sequence was incredible
to me visually with the music everything
going on tying in the whole episode
together was awesome and like i've said
this goes to the editing too at this
show this show for me the end of the day
with euphoria season one and season two
here now they're filming in film in
season two which is really cool i mean
it's god level cinematography god level
editing and god level directing and i
would even say god level music selection
here that's something that sticks to me
the show and i think this was some of
zendaya's best acting in the show yet as
well but as a whole to show i'd say it's
very good acting i'm not
ready to say god level acting the show
yet and i'm not ready to say god level
writing it either because i have some
problems where it's so character driven
which is great really good character
writing but there's just a
missing core to the show we're missing
like
where does it all tie and connect to
each other i think sometimes
we'll see even in this episode maddie's
story and maddie's b-day story like
there's just parts that don't connect
enough to me to real where i'm even like
when is the last time roo even talked to
some of these characters so i feel like
the show kind of doesn't have enough
kind of a connecting tissue to connect
it all together sometimes but that's the
story for another day we'll talk about
the sea as a whole but let's go to
maddie's b-day party here so we're
seeing nate's like sort of kind of back
with maddie basically and it was
interesting because we're kind of all
seeing like okay is he gonna go get the
tape from her why is he there they don't
really show anything like that that
still could have happened though and
we're seeing that's kind of cutting
between different timelines with this
maddie nate story and cassie but you see
in this big moment with cassie and nate
and them fighting again always amazing
performances by jacob valordi here is
nate and an amazing sydney sweeney who
always kills it and cassie's like if i
knew you would have gotten back together
with maddie i wouldn't have done this
and cassie's basically like you and
maddie are toxic together i'm not gonna
let that happen and she does like nate
saying blackmail him but he's calling
her out saying she does everything for
herself
but i love this moment with cats where
she's like showing like i can be a
psycho too and it's scary and you see it
in sydney sweeney's eyes how she
presents that really well and it makes
me wonder we haven't seen everything at
cass yet where she can go as a person
and you have predictions that people are
saying she might commit suicide that
she's losing it but it also might lead
to this
character arc where she's trying to like
not be afraid of maddie and actually put
her foot down and be more crazy than the
maddie we've seen so it's interesting
and fascinating character of cassie and
i like what they're doing with lexi here
where they had started her writing this
play and that she's observing everything
i liked that they were showing her
witnessing her sister suffering but
writing it through her play and how
she's writing lines of basically
verbatim of what her sister said to her
in real life i thought that was pretty
cool but i will say ever since they set
that up about really leaning into lexi
being the observer of everything which
they've alluded to in season one but
this season they've really honed in on i
did think it got a little almost comical
how much they're like showing us lexi
observed everything okay we get it like
her watching him in the hot tub i mean
she's sitting on that windowsill for a
long time watching them where it just
gets like creepy and over the top it's
like okay we get it you know like she
observes things you don't have to make
the point of it every single scene with
her now there's almost two on the nose
and we see obviously with nate showing
up cassie's drinking like a fish at this
party the mom's not being a responsible
mom at all she's getting hammered not
really even attending cassie's needs
here and even though lexi knows what's
going on again it's just her observing
and not really doing anything now the
character's storyline has kind of
suffered a lot nothing's really much
happenings with cat this season
i don't even know where it's going but
she's telling maddie i can't stand ethan
you know she gets something good finally
she's like i'm miserable i'd like to see
more of the why she's miserable about
this i think we need more time with that
cat and even story because it's just a
lot of talking about not showing but
maddie's like do what feels good to you
and one maybe it's maybe showing you a
one blimp of goodness in maddie that she
is a good friend to cat of what we've
seen advice-wise so that kind of shows
here but again i'm not really interested
in this cat story because they're not
giving me enough to cling on to the the
webcam stuff was more interesting like
can we go back to that and kind of
explore that especially how ethan would
handle that something like it's not
really going anywhere now when cassie
has this moment in this drunken state
where she chose to put on the swimsuit
the line of the episode goes to cat
though the comedic climber she's like
well that is certainly a choice i think
that was hysterical and i think people
are going to love that now
the only thing that annoys me sometimes
to create a choice with euphoria here is
with every form of art you know it's
coming from the filmmaker's personal
taste things that connect to him right
but there has to be a line drawn where
like but does it work in the reality of
the show and
it works having sinead o'connor you know
the music playing in the bar with cow's
story but to have the character of
cassie singing that specific song by
sinead o'connor is like no way i'm sorry
like
not today are they singing that song
it's so random and it just doesn't fit
cassie to me to even like that song so
it reminded me where again it's cool
that you have all these easter eggs last
season we're at the costume party but
it's all these 90s films you're kind of
like this is the creator's films he
loves and he's referencing but is it
every character who would get into this
nowadays i don't i don't think it's too
much of a stretch and especially here
with cass was kind of roman i was like
okay she's not really the k i just don't
buy the character be singing so connor
at this moment it feels too much of a
you know nod to stuff of the filmmaker's
case but you see that this like ugly
side of maddie is reminded to the
audience here where it's like it really
rears its head where she's how the way
she's talking to nate to the point where
it's like nate is so unlikable but it's
almost making you feel bad for nate here
because she's just being like ridiculous
maddie here the stuff she's saying but
it's also showing cassie observing this
and seeing that toxicity she was talking
about between
maddie and nate how they're just awful
for each other but also cassie cannot
even take the stuff matty's saying about
all the stuff nate's promised her like
you know how much he loves her and how
he wants to have babies with her and
that's exactly where cassie barf's here
you know there's people who've been in
the shoes of uh cassie here where
they're you know really drunk making
horrible decisions and you barf it's
completely embarrassing but people
witnessed it and i'm definitely someone
who's witnessed it at parties and i
always feel bad for that person and i
always you know they feel bad for cassie
a lot here she's made dumb choices but
you know she's also had a lot of bad
stuff happen to her she's a young teen
and it's hard to watch now after that
they quickly show a scene we get a
little bit of fez here but it's setting
up a future storyline where he's
informed that the baby mama is now
asking questions of mouse so that's
going to lead to something now let's go
to the cal staff now this really to me
felt forced in this episode that of the
placement of where in the season they
put all this cal big moments where i
actually would have liked cal's
confrontation with his family last
episode i think that would have cut
really well with the cow backstory
because i think it just interrupts the
rhythm of this whole episode between
maddie's party and the ruse storyline to
shove in these cow moments it like stops
the flow and everything i'm feeling from
those stories
it just felt like why didn't we just put
this last week i think it would have hit
harder anyway because we were seeing the
cow backstory it's a nice touch him
going the bar having that memory of him
with derek this moment where it was his
happiest moment was life leading to this
most tragic moment where you know he has
to live this fake life he has this baby
and he's talking about his family how
everyone they're all hypocrites they're
living these double lives everyone has
their secrets and he's really opening
himself up now about him you know having
sex with men you know and just feel like
he'd never be himself but he just i it's
so hard to have sympathy with his
character because he just says even to a
guy like nate again who's not someone
you have sympathy for but just saying
stuff like you're my biggest regret like
saying that's his son it's just brutal
and he's very martyr syndrome where yes
he had this tough
thing happening in his life but he
doesn't also take any
self-responsibility he's now finally
saying stuff like you know i wasn't you
know a good dad it's the sins of the
father situation but again there's not
enough sympathy for me for this
character to even you know feel bad for
him because he's just done horrible
stuff and treated his own kids really
bad but i'm not really crazy you know
about the story of cow in a sense of is
it really necessary do we have to go
into this whole cow
backstory and then have this big moment
with cal i don't really know i feel like
maybe it's a good idea and it's yes
giving more weight to this character and
also
probably leading up to more sympathy for
nate but i think it takes a lot of time
and i'm just not that interested in it
to be honest so that to me was a little
weaker in the episode but with the
moments like i talked about with rue and
jewel's story at the end here
specifically that moment where she's on
all the drugs and she's thinking of her
father and also again this church organ
sequence at the end was just awesome and
that's the thing with euphoria right
it's like i said it's amazing
cinematography music directing editing
and really good acting and a lot of that
shined here and i would give this
episode a 9.1 for sure but i again it's
not this show euphoria or i'm like
always running to see it and watch it
it's so damn depressing which i don't
mind you know and i like tragic stories
but it does feel like it just needs a
little more relief sprinkled in here
because you sit back and like watching
four hours of just complete you know
depression that maybe the only relief
we've got in the whole season so far and
it's just not enough was having fez hit
nate in the head with a liquor bottle
but we need a little more of that
because it's getting just like i need
something i need something to have a
little hope or something
to also just get me more invested in the
show meaning of conflict like there's
still not enough conflict going on like
you just wonder where is this all going
and i worry that it's just becoming too
circular and that like what's the end
game here you know is it always just
going to be a show where it's like rue
leaves jewels now they're back together
ruby loops jules leaves her again so i
hope it doesn't just become repetitive
because it i just wonder what's the
vision at the end of the day of this but
there's a lot of strong stuff here and
it's always great with character but i
do think it could be a more interesting
plot to make me want to keep coming back
because it's just one of those shows i'm
not like always excited to watch it but
it again is such quality so and that's
expected with hbo as well but let me
know what you thought of this episode
what you think of the season as a whole
so far maybe compared to season one i'd
love to hear your thoughts i'll be
reviewing every episode of euphoria
season two from here on out i also
reviewed the special episode of rue's
episode which i really enjoyed so you
can dig check out that review and i also
reviewed a couple episodes from season
one if you want to go back and watch
those but please follow me on steve
raleigh's show on twitter instagram tick
tock for more of me please subscribe so
you don't miss one of my reviews of you
for you and i'll see you next time